focus on your strengths so I was
recently thinking about going to a
conference and I don't go to a lot of
conferences unless I'm speaking at them
anymore and it was one conference that I
was really curious about and I asked a
couple people who had been to it last
sure and I said what are your
impressions should I go to this or not
and they said the content is okay but
the best part to go for is the
networking and I told them I'm not a
great networker
I hate networking it's one of the things
that I just absolutely hate doing I'm
not the kind of guy who goes up to
somebody on an airplane who's sitting
next to me and strikes up a conversation
you may think I'm really outgoing and
talkative by watching these videos but
in reality I'm just pretty much to
myself and so going to a conference
where the main benefit is networking for
me is just I want to take a gun to my
head it's something that I I would hate
doing I would have no fun doing and it's
not something that I'm really good at
and one of the guys who I asked advice
from said well maybe that's a skill you
can work on you can get better at and at
some point you'll you'll enjoy maybe get
some contacts out of and that is the
exact opposite way of thinking that I
have see I think there are two ways you
can look at it I can look at my
strengths and go all-in and those and
and be amazing that what I'm really good
at and focus on that and copy my
weaknesses with with other people or
completely avoid them or I'm gonna try
to make myself the most well-rounded
person there is and try to improve my
weaknesses and that's what a lot of
people will do they'll try to improve
their weaknesses so try to say here's
something I'm not good at and try to get
better at it and then what ends up
happening you keep struggling with it
and your progress is so slow and as a
result you don't get the results that
you want you don't get the big returns
you don't get the big growth in your
business where it's far more productive
to focus on what you're really good at
and compliment yourself with other
people who can help you on things your
weekend so my way around networking is I
speak at events I get asked to speak at
a lot of events and afterwards people
come up and want to talk to me about
what I'm doing and shared their business
ideas my way around network
is creating a lot of noise in my
business right so I make these YouTube
videos right we have almost 6 million
views on the channel I'll do a lot on
Twitter I'll do a lot on Facebook I get
people coming to me because I create
such noise so the way around being the
guy out networking and handing out
business cards is to kick up a lot of
dust and your industry since you guys
are watching my youtube channel the way
I do it here is when I started my
channel I did everything myself and I
might do one video a month because it
took me so long to film myself and edit
it and publish it and do the research
took a really long time now I have a
team I've got one person who helps me do
the research and all the famous
entrepreneur profiles that I'm doing
I've got one person who helps me edit
all the videos and publish them on the
channel I've got one person now it helps
me fill the video so I don't have to
worry about that side of it and all I
have to do is show up and talk which is
what I'm best at and I can get more
practice at and I can get better at and
now it could produce 1314 videos a week
instead of one a month because I've bet
on my strengths so you need to do the
same thing for your business but I don't
know what you're really good at look at
what you are really really really good
at and then figure out how can it be one
of the best in the world at and
everything else that you need to get
done in your business delegate it away
to other people who love doing that side
of things instead of you trying to do
everything and be mediocre right
everything and not being able to spend
time to really grow your company so I'd
love to know from you what are your
strengths what's the one thing that you
have the ability to be one of the best
in the world that leave in the comments
below I'd love to hear from you thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon